there's a crisis of meaning that is
happening among young people that crisis
of meaning is directly related to loss
of religion in the united states
there is no doubt about this okay the
suicide rates have tripled among young
people in the united states between 2006
and 2016.
there's a reason for this right now
young american children growing up in
the freest most prosperous country in
the history of mankind
are killing themselves at record rates
and this is happening
for a very specific reason it is
happening because we are not providing
the meaning
and i mean i don't mean the people in
this room really because i think all of
us spend our lives trying to figure out
how we provide that meaning for our kids
i mean our culture is militantly opposed
to us providing that meaning for our
children
they're supposed to find meaning in
whatever the social justice buzzword of
the day is
they're supposed to find meaning in the
idea that they get to define their own
meaning
that their morality is above god's
morality that there is no transcendent
truth there is just the truth that's
inside of you there's just your truth
well guess what human beings suck at
finding their truth
because as all religious people know
there is a difference between your truth
which is just called what you're feeling
like today
and the truth which has nothing to do
with you and comes from a higher place